a
お仕事で青森に来ておりまして今日は青森の心霊スポットに
な時は珍しいメンバーウエーブの生産も林さんよろしくお願いします
とっ
天才うちはたーーーーでえいたクズだよっ
ですねをやっていますからね song にでちょっと色んなシーンですこと見てたん
ですけどあ俺ってやっぱヤバイらしいんですよ
米韓というかそういうのがその代表格と言ったらやっぱり恐山とか
ダーマーからわーずそうかそう聞いたことがあるそんなサーマンキングで見てて覚えた
んですけど
シャーマンキング出てくる
出てくれてる子ならばパッソ夢じゃないですか罰 x 有名だからもう結構ヤバいー
まん6が悪いってだけなら青のいいとがいっぱいありますけどまぁ霊的な疾患地点で
いうとちょっとこぼりゅーみーなー
素敵な言葉でありますねはいそれで今回行けばですね
母ローラー山荘という場所でございます
あるであろう拉致5分
有名なタイミングですね
夜中の12時半今何やったねもうやなぁ
というわけであろうらー酸素をどんな場所がちょっと説明していきたいと思います
カローラ酸素と青森県八戸市にあるんですけども
精神に病を持った神座を構成するためにつくられた施設がそこにあるらしいでしょ
一部のウザさでは表向きは統制施設ではあるなぁ
裏でま
家族の同意のもとで神座を殺害しているとされています
ひょっ
敷地内には大量の出現されたひとつの骨がー
埋まってるらしいです a これはキー食べてお腹いっぱいですよ
帰ろうかーっ俺えっ
もうちょっとちょっと見ていきましょうし強敵中身があるという噂もあってそのためか
から村周りにはいくつかの石像が立ってるらしくて
ぬ不思議な形相の
象とか首がない地蔵など中には象半身が人間で
下半身が着物姿の中シーンはに出てくるような怪物の像もあるらしいです
ポンタウルスみたいねぇこういったでしょ護衛などその建物の窓にはねあの鐵猴子だけ
じゃなくて木の板とかも着つけられているらしくてすごく不気味だ建物が感じらしい
です
はい結構有名らしいですちなみに青森県がなかったと m 5本指に入るぐらいの
全然入ると思うんでまぁよはいというわけで今回
なんと空母の西さんが運転してくださっているのでのまま現地までよろしくお願い致し
ますよ違います
[音楽]
た図面最近でとしたと思う
ブーバー目立ったにょああっんですけど
それは流石に無いさぁいや言ってさあ
れっ
なると感じですかパワームーブのサイズにお聞きしたいんですけど
たテミンが生むの口リーダーになれる可能性はどれくらいですかパ
5%にも nai kono karada 存知で計などではいえばずに行って
くださいね一緒にレーって睡眠不足とかちょっと弱っている人に取り付きやすくなる
らしいです
はい
つまりに
行木は
voodoo
50 letter in サールプレゼントばいいですねビッグボーイやるよきっと
ウィッグ fan
多い濃厚さがまあだいぶ暗くなってきましたねー
まだ該当どうぞ
づらいチーム多いです磯山& bar 調べたんですけど
73ぐらいですねあと7年くらいで作るみたいです
よろしくお願いますはいはちょっといいができません
こわ e
鹿にパーカー着たところ
街灯が極端に少なくなりましたん
右本です
中杉かナビ外ってこと違うね
左ウォーカーですね第二は右つってくれるって言うじゃないですよね
お前すかねぇ変ですその目的地は左側です
僕だけだった不振で胴体はああ
彼はなく左こうこれぞ
ブーバーんですけども
ちょっと道がヌーディいきたいとおもいますっ待ってヤバい雰囲気が
はいこれですね
これがえっと近くにある観音ズっていうお寺ですね
この小国可能な酸素がありますやっぺえ
なぜで阿部創造六合区梅光園が現地に入っただけで
可能な酸素吹までつきました
結構やばいですねマールの苦行美元が回答が s ですかー
お墓もため近くやそうなそこがすぐお墓なんですけどどこの隣のお寺とかお墓が民では
なくてその奥にあるカローラ山荘という手術マリが本場なる
ス米を上げていきたいとおもいます行ってみましたん
ええええええ
これやばいですねー
体羽鳥アナタっちゃうってだ
だこのさんもやってみてください
下方婚はたっ
ちょずつどうぞ
びっくりした何生池大いやいやをいつもは3やろうよ俺は食べる言わなきゃいけない
から
ここで行ったほうがいいんだよたぶんここらへんですねあるのあっうっすか
だからぼっちを超えないといけないぽい
これ本当に7月2日ヤバくないすかどんどん頭じゃない
右もすごいですよね
もう前科やまりな機がすごいじゃあこっちってこっちでみましょうはいここ周辺などが
合ってるねー
当院これこれ多分ですかこれポリスこれ住めたら絶対来ですね
秋って声だっ
中国には日は切ってる
4肘付れる
これじゃいけないんですけど不自然にも来なかったですか
命はちゃんと聞か聞いて何してるんだね
動物にしてはおけないですかなんか細かいパキパキがここでメタだめだ
カッコ the おり的な強されますより的なことないってさっきさあんなバツがつい
た3さん
今度も f 2
ないですねないんですよ
まったくしないでしょまったくしないです
納豆は1当然よ
何さっきは来なかった2つめちゃくちゃ1巻発パッチパチ貼ってる
none
ほんとだどう新しいですっ
象みたいなのにまともないっすけどないっすね
バックパックスタッ
あれどけっ
ana
youtube ない方がします
ます数
[拍手]
スペシャルボスでした
こちらばいいな
うーん何かなんかくらぽく言っています
スペック c もんやばいですねこの先何があるのかあったもうちょっとせっかく来た
ね奥まで行ってみます
2片手でちょっと待ってもやい市がやばいつ目はひっくりしたーー
5コース強い
[音楽]
本当に森の中に入っていく感じだなっ
ねっ
ますっ
今さあ子供みたいなご意見だと思いますけど
聞かじゃねーかって気を付けます復興ちょっと聞くとそっか聞こえませんでさぁ
操作ぞちょっとちょっと
一括で聞こえたよねー
って聞こえたんだっけ
バッテリーみたいですよ
って聞かれましたちょっとだけなんか
子どもの
すみます子供これますよ
me
南海変だよな
大戻りません
じゃあ明らかせてますよね何か何か知ってました
子供の声は月
間違ってねいっぱいさんおきくださいボケちょっと滝きた2つよね
今日完璧杭ちょっと趣味田子のです入ってねーから動画に塞がれてそうだなぁ
塞がれてそうですよ
この機能や方もすごいですよね
どうやったらこのう
[音楽]
アンコール
あのくれうん
とても仲です
も山ぬかでした
創世
非常か浩探検隊で乗ってネットで見た時よりだいぶ日にちが経ってたり環境が変わっ
たりしてて
どうぞとかも良いの見つからないですねぞうが取り交わされた可能性もあるして
ちょっと
ん
何とも言えないしあとすぐ足場が悪いのと危ないんで一旦引き返しましょう
えっ
言いますこれはネット来ないですかあれでしょで打ってえっなにあれ
ネット白くない
曰くねーそうですよねー
ちょっとこれぞ使うといけないんだよ
を取りますけど
色がすごいする
[音楽]
結構強かったってないが本当に役をテレビで観てねバターなど本当にやばいとやばい
なって思いますあるわけですね
あ終わりますんでスポットもっとても怖かったです
ずっと山田次の心霊スポットでお会いしましょうさらばじゃ
事をはずぞ
[音楽]